hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm gonna be
checking out the trailer today for a
movie called in the heart of the sea I
saw the first trailer for this looks
good I'll be perfectly honest I'm not
the biggest fan of sea adventure films I
like all genres of films with sea
adventure ones excluding the great
Pirates of the Caribbean franchise man
remember how good that French like that
first one was so promising yeah I mean
it's Ron Howard and Chris Hemsworth and
they didn't rush together which is
fantastic I'm sure this movie it looks
interesting actually you know Moby Dick
Moby mod dick brief startling violence
what is it listen
it's beautiful
promised me to come back
brothers that's run hours
do you family what go No
so yeah stay serious yeah
I will not
we will survive
that film is gonna be intense on IMAX I
feel like the only way I can truly
experience this movie is on something
like IMAX 2 because like the way it's
shot is meant to capture something so
visually dark but beautiful and I I
think on IMAX that's when it looks its
best and that's when you could really
feel the grand scope of things so yeah I
am so gonna be watching that at IMAX
chris hemsworth he is good at playing
bad asses I would like to see him play
like a really big [ __ ] one day and see
if he can pull it off cuz right now I
don't see that I don't see that acting
range in you I just see you be one
Hollywood hunk movie star which career
do you want come on no it looks intense
and I like seeing that like psychology
of the characters falling a party I mean
that happens a lot in the C movies the
last one I can think of it I saw at
least this year was Noah when you know
they were the whole journey on the ark
and you know the sea just looks like it
has horrible things to you the back it
up without this mission that you have is
just gonna bring out the worst in you
the scene like these guys just
psychologically deteriorate I don't know
why I get a high off of that but it is
like [ __ ] kind of cool to see that in
a film this makes the adventure that
much more rewarding if they actually win
by the end my one concern is because I
am gonna want a film that has thrills in
it throughout you know but something
about it to me seems like it might be a
little bit of a misleading trailer where
it's mainly character and then like a
few moments of peril but which makes me
sound like such a lousy audience member
I like movies that do that but I feel
like for this particular film I want
something that does have the thrills at
least periodically throughout but it's
just a trailer who knows
I can't wait to see what I don't know
rotten tomatoes has to say about it
something and I important and whatever
but yeah I'll be checking it out just
for the visual experience on my max for
sure anyway guys thanks for telling me
that trailer was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real ly Jax where you can see Moby Dick
one day if you win the contest I'm
saying I'm gonna start a contest up
where the winner will see my penis gonna
be started off shoutouts again so go to
facebook.com slash the real rejects
shoutouts where you say something
interesting and earn yourself a
shout-out would have thought the word
dick and [ __ ] would be so popular
that you name a character Moby Dick like
the author who no one knows I
I mean who wrote Moby Dick does anyone
really know you must honor realize that
Moby Dick would be referred to as Ryan's
penis one day